bonjour à tous je m'appelle jimmy
mohamed
je suis médecin
je travaille à paris je n'ai pas que des
défauts évidemment et je vais vous
parler de mon expérience j'ai eu la
chance ces derniers temps de participer
à des émissions débats à la fois à la
télé mais aussi à la radio sur des
sujets assez divers et variés ça pouvait
parler de sujets de société
en passant par l'immigration la banlieue
la justice et pour être tout à fait
honnête ça se passait bien
ça se passait même très bien les gens
étaient vraiment sympas avec moi j'ai
rien à leur reprocher il était compétent
et j'étais presque mis en lumière et
donc j'ai apprécié l'exercice
et pourtant j'ai décidé de tout arrêter
j'ai mis du temps avant de le faire
puisque finalement ça m'a coûté puisque
l'orgueil peut en prendre un coup
pourquoi tous pourquoi tout arrêté alors
que ça se passe plutôt bien et je me
suis rendu compte de plusieurs choses la
première c'est qu'elle mérite imiter
edge pour parler de sujets de société
on me donne un micro je peux parler mais
est-ce que je suis plus légitime que mon
voisin que mon boulanger ou ou même que
vous et puis ça va conduire notamment
par ma fonction à un billet qu'on
appelle le biais des autorités étant
donné que vous avez en face de vous un
médecin vous dit forcément ce qu'il a à
dire est intéressant et j'aurais
tendance à l'écouté et à lui faire
confiance à thé point que je me faisais
un peu trop confiance j'avais
l'impression d'avoir presque réponse à
tout alors que je n'avais probablement
réponse à rien ça j'ai mis du temps
avant de le comprendre
jusqu'à ce que je me rappelle de
l'histoire de socrate socrates grand
philosophe n'était pas un orateur
quelqu'un qui vous faisaient réfléchir
quelqu'un qui était là pour amener de la
réflexion et secrète a été jugé puisque
on pensait qu'ils voulaient corrompre la
jeunesse c'était l'accusation qui était
fait et qu'il voulait créer de nouveaux
dieux socrates pour se défendre a décidé
d'interroger des gens puissent qu'on lui
reprochait finalement de ne pas être à
la hauteur des autres savants et secrète
en interrogeant tous les grands savants
s'est rendu compte d'une chose il a dit
ça à l'assemblée écoutez je suis le plus
grand des savants évidemment il a
commencé à agacer tout le monde il a dit
oui j'ai rencontré tous les savants je
peux vous dire que je suis le meilleur
d'entre eux pour une simple et bonne
raison
c'est qu'ils sont tous convaincus de
tout savoir alors que moi ce que je sais
c'est que je ne sais rien tandis que les
autres croient tout savoir et c'est ça
l'écueil que je pouvais avoir c'est de
croire que je savais tout alors que
certainement je ne savais rien et c'est
exactement ce qui se passe notamment
dans les émissions souvent de débat où
chacun apporte son ressenti ce qu'ils
pensent être vrai alors que ce n'est
peut-être pas la réalité des choses
alors vous allez me dire bon c'est un
peu triste tout ça et effectivement moi
je me suis rendu compte que quand je
participe et ses émissions eh bien
j'avais deux catégories de personnes les
premières personnes qui étaient d'accord
avec moi et qui était contente de
m'écouter puisque finalement j'allais
dans leur sens et ça leur faisait du
bien et puis l inverse celle qui était
contente de me détester
c'est un peu paradoxal et des fois on se
fait du mal on est content d'entendre
quelqu'un qui nous énervent et
finalement je me rendais compte que ma
l'opinion n'avançait pas alors que moi
j'étais là pour ça faire évoluer l'image
faire changer les choses alors que tout
rester strictement pareil on regardait
le moment passé mais les gens ne
changeait pas alors ça on peut le
comprendre puisque et plusieurs biens
qui vont entrer en considération le
premier c'est ce qu'on appelle le biais
de confirmation vous avez quelqu'un en
face de vous qui va vous conforter dans
votre hypothèse vous allez donc être
content de cette hypothèse puisque elle
vous conforte dans votre idée et du coup
par conséquent vous allez vous toujours
chercher les mêmes informations auprès
des mêmes personnes
c'est ce qu'on a pu voir notamment avec
la chloroquine chloroquine qui était
supposée être efficace et à partir du
moment où vous vous étiez persuadé
qu'elles étaient efficaces vous alliez
chercher des études qui vont vous
conforter dans cette hypothèse
et vous n'allez plus remettre en
question ce qui se passe autour de vous
même chose lorsque vous avez une
information pense aux anti vaccins par
exemple ils ne vont plus remettre en
cause l'information qu'ils ont elle
vient tel quel et lorsqu'on vous dit que
vous allez avoir une puce 5g lorsque
vous allez de vacciner eh bien ils ne
vont même pas se poser la question de la
crédibilité de l'information et vous
allez en permanence vous servir de la
même source
donc vous allez vous conforter dans
votre erreur et puis à une deuxième
chose puisque je vous dis que finalement
on va regarder ses émissions où la télé
ou l'écouté la radio car on est content
d'entendre quelqu'un ou au contraire on
va apprécier le détester et souvent on
apprécie encore plus
détesté les personnes à ce moment là
alors est quelque chose d'assez naturel
c'est humain et on peut pas lutter
contre c'est ce qu'on appelle le biais
de négativité ça on le doit à nos
ancêtres les chasseurs cueilleurs les
chasseurs cueilleurs pour survivre
devaient se méfier de tout en permanence
lorsqu'il voyait un fruit qui avait
l'air appétissant ou une baie ils
devaient se méfier car s'il l'a mangé
qu'elles étaient toxiques qu'ils
allaient mourir c'était en quelque sorte
pour assurer la survie de l'espèce et
nous avons gardé ça en nous ce biais de
négativité 70% de la population là ce
qui fait que nous retenons plus une
information déplaisante que plaisante
vous allez plus se retenir une critique
qu'elle va vous faire beaucoup plus de
mal qu une qualité qu'on pourra vous
donner même chose de vos échecs on s'en
souvient très bien et on a du mal à se
souvenir des succès eh bien c'est
exactement ce qui se passe d'ailleurs on
peut le constater sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment sur twitter une
information négative va circuler
beaucoup plus rapidement et de façon
beaucoup plus importante
même si elle n'est pas tout à fait vrai
qu'une émotion une information positive
alors qu'on est une chose très simple
quand vous voyez quelqu'un sur twitter
et ça peut m'arriver vous énerver et
bien ce qu'on va faire la réaction qu'on
aura tous et de commenter et de
critiquer ou de s'indigner
alors qu'il suffit de faire une chose
toute simple c'est de se désabonner du
compte pour autant on a du mal à le
faire et on n'y arrive pas et on reste
obsédé par ça alors vous allez me dire
de toute façon peu importe
tu me dis que je suis obsédé par sa non
moi j'arrive à faire la part des choses
c'est ce qu'on se dit tous dans son for
intérieur et je vais vous prouver le
contraire
c'est l'expérience que de jeunes ce qui
a mis en place qu'ils visent à montrer
que les pensées refoulées finissent par
devenir obsédante et pour ça il a fait
un test très simple qu'on va reproduire
tous ensemble vous avez le droit pendant
quelques secondes de penser à ce que
vous voulez libre à vous de penser
vraiment à tout ce que vous voulez je
vous demande simplement une chose c'est
de ne pas penser un ours blanc vous
pensez à ce que vous voulez vos vacances
vos amis ce que vous allez faire ce soir
ce que vous avez mangé ce que vous allez
manger mais s'il vous plaît ne pensez
pas un ours blanc dans cet exercice de
ski demandé à l'assemblée
d'agiter une petite sonnette évidemment
n'a pas de sonnette donc on va remplacer
l'exercice par autre chose
si jamais vous voyez c'est ours blancs
alors que je vous ai demandé de ne pas
le regarder
vous avez juste en dessous de la vidéo
un petit pouce pour dire like j'aime
si vous ne voyez pas c'est ours blancs
et bien je prends le risque de m'exposer
adn like ad je n'aime pas donc fait le
bilan
vous pensez à ce que vous voulez sauf
cet ours blancs si vous le voyez
évidemment vous cliquez sur live sinon
vous ne cliquez pas et ce sera tant pis
pour moi
alors vous allez dire c'est triste que
tu racontes c'est que les débats servent
normalement dans notre démocratie à
faire évoluer le pignon et on a la
chance de s'exprimer et une vie que ça
ne sert à rien mais comment faire dans
ces cas là pour changer les gens eh bien
je pense qu'il faut tout simplement
commencer par ne rien faire ne cherchez
pas à convaincre les gens c'est
peut-être la meilleure façon de les
convaincre
vous allez faire évoluer l'opinion sans
même un seul argument et en faisant
quelque chose d'assez simple à mon avis
c'est de montrer le bon exemple
alors dit comme ça ça paraît pas très
intéressant pour autant il faut bien
comprendre que j'ai une intime
conviction que j'ai pu changer des
personnes au cours de ma vie sans
simplement dire une seule chose mais en
essayant de montrer le bon comportement
au quotidien
alors on le sait on a dans notre cerveau
des cellules les neurones et on a des
normes très particulier qu'on appelle
des neurones miroirs ses neurones
miroirs vont s'activer par la simple
pensée ou la simple vue de quelque chose
ce qui veut donc dire que nos
comportements vont pouvoir être copiés
lorsque on les observe
on le sait le bâillement est contagieux
le rire l'est aussi
c'est pour ça que dans certaines séries
on va mettre des reer pour le provoquer
et donc pourquoi pas les comportes
pourquoi pas avoir un comportement
contagieux et un bon comportement et je
pense que c'est de cette façon qu'on
peut changer les choses
c'est pour ça
e j'aimerais vraiment vous compreniez
que ne rien faire est totalement
différent de faire rien il ya un moment
il ya dans votre vie où vous ne faites
rien pour autant il se passe quelque
chose c'est pendant votre sommeil
pendant votre sommeil on est tous
d'accord nous ne faisons rien on ferme
les yeux on attend que ça passe si on se
repose pour autant dans votre cerveau il
se passe des choses extraordinaires
on le sait vous allez synthétiser des
hormones leurs hormones de croissance
qui permet aux enfants de grandir des
hormones qui vont vous empêcher de vous
réveiller pour avoir faim pour aller
uriner
et puis tout un tas de paramètres qui
ont évolué comme votre tension
artérielle
la fréquence cardiaque ou même la
température eh bien figurez vous que
lorsque vous dormez vous avez une chose
extraordinaire qui se passe au niveau de
vos chromosomes tout au bout des
chromosomes on a quelque chose qui
s'appelle des télomères
c'était le maire ne cote pas pour une
information en particulier mais elles
ont un rôle majeur dans la préservation
de notre capital génétique plus ces
télomères se raccourcissent plus la
cellule va être détruite et plus votre
espérance de vie va se réduire
eh bien lorsque vous dormez vous avez
quasiment des petite couturière des
petits ouvriers qui vont venir réparer
ces télomères qui s'appelle des
télomérase ça veut donc dire que même
lorsque vous ne faites rien votre
cerveau fait à votre place j'ai mis du
temps à comprendre de l'importance de
rien faire puisque on vit dans une
société où vous êtes en permanence en
mouvement en permanence en activité et
l'inactivité est vue comme presque de la
paresse quelque chose de négatif et j'ai
le souvenir pendant mes études de
médecine en première année il y avait un
concours un peu difficile et quasiment
tous les jours aux alentours de 17
heures j'ai décidé de rien faire c'était
pas vraiment une pause parce que je
faisais rien je pouvais être devant la
télévision mais sans trop la regarder
mais je ne faisais rien et j'ai mis du
temps avant de comprendre que même en ne
faisant rien eh bien je faisais quelque
chose et pour ça un ami m'a parlé d'une
expérience que je vous propose de faire
aussi à la maison si besoin
c'est prendre un verre d'eau un verre
d'eau que vous remplissez simplement à
moitié ce verre d'eau vous mettez
simplement de dans une goutte de
grenadine ou tel que ça une goutte de
grenadine dans un verre d'eau vous
partez
et puis vous revenez au bout d'une heure
au bout d'une heure vous allez vous
rendre compte que ce verre d'eau s'est
transformé en grenadine en verre de
grenadine
ça veut dire que même lorsqu'on ne fait
rien eh bien vous faites quelque chose
acceptons de ne rien faire c'est
peut-être la première des choses à faire
de la même façon que pendant ces
quelques minutes vous n'avez rien fait
j'espère malgré tout qu'on a fait
quelque chose tous ensemble